Osman: We're looking at an ad from the Sunday
Chicago Tribune from July 8th, 1917, actually.
And this is of a house that is, according
to the caption, being built.
And then there's a huge headline that says:
“You can own an American home.”
So, striking headline.
Osman: I think it's important to think about
the fact that “You can own an American home”
is in every newspaper that circulated throughout
the Chicago area.
So anybody who picks up that newspaper is
being addressed by this sentence but furthermore,
they're being told that they cannot just own
an American home but distinctly American architecture
by a distinct American architect.
Probably the most famous architect of that
time, 1917, Frank Lloyd Wright.
On the shop drawings and on the folio that
was published by the Richards Company, every
drawing that we saw said, usually in the lower
right, patent applied for which for us was
a clue that Wright was interested in interfacing
with industry and creating intellectual property
from his designs.
And typically a work of art will be copyrighted
but an invention is something that you patent.
So it was an interesting idea to think about
architecture as something that you could patent.
Skjonsberg: I think the point is since the
beginning of his career, Wright has been very
interested in how the machine can be an emancipatory
thing.
That this is the forerunner of democracy as
he calls it.
So the evils that are experienced through
industrial process talking about inequity
in labor or ecological degradation which was
already apparent at that time.
So, he was interested in architect as an artist
being able to harness this emancipatory quality
of the machine and bring that to everyone.
Everyone who picks up a paper, as it turns
out.
Osman: I think what's important about having
a factory built house is that in order to
get the common person, as it were, to have
access to a house, you'd need to reduce the
cost of the labor that it would take to make
that house.
So engaging the factory meant that you could
reduce the amount of labor that was on the
job site.
So for Wright, engaging in the factory was
really about democratizing access to houses
more generally but also, of course, to his
own authored beautiful houses.
Osman: So in the nineteen teens, when he's
approached by the Richards Company, the labor
market is very expensive in the U.S. and as
a result, engaging in factory labor would
have made sense.
By the 1930s, during the Great Depression,
the labor is very cheap.
So Wright moves away from factory made houses
precisely because he can make houses as he
always wanted to in the most beautifully crafted
way possible with intricate and incredibly
beautiful details.
The difference between the prefabricated house
made in the factory and the houses that we're
looking at here is that these houses were
made actually by master craftsmen.
The idea was to capitalize on the cheap labor
market during the Great Depression and give
access to people who, otherwise, wouldn't
have access to Frank Lloyd Wright homes to
a system of houses that he called Usonian
which would populate the entire continent
of the United States.
Skjonsberg: So this brings us maybe from the
houses that were built in wood to those that
were built in concrete.
The Usonian automatic system which was intended
to be built of concrete blocks.
And these were intended to be made by the
home builders themselves from the soil coming
from their own property.
So the intention was and several of these
houses were made that way that the clients,
usually husband and wife, would work together
making the blocks.
They would work together establishing the
slab for the house.
These vertical rods were situated at regular
intervals at two foot on center around the
perimeter.
The blocks were slid down onto these rods
and as subsequent courses were laid up, horizontal
rods were also inserted.
This was a definitely a paradigm shift that
it goes away from industrialized products
to locally sourced site specific mode of production.
Skjonsberg: I think Wright was concerned about
the role of architecture in society.
He was ambitious that architecture not be
lost as a cultural force.
And so his ambition for first systems and
then for standards were all in a way were
guided by the ambition that it be something
that's a cultural force.
So when you talk about Usonian house, Usonia
to him is a term for a culturally mature United
States.
So if you talk about, “you too can own an
American home,” in this case, it's talking
about an aspiration for a greater society
actually.